[Music]
Reed thank you so much for being here
today really excited to be here thank
you for having me of course so let's
dive in talk to me about exactly what
your company does yeah so verad dermic
is a medical Dermatology company and
really the origin of the company was the
idea that there are more than 3,000 skin
conditions many of which have no FDA
approved treatment have had minimal
innovation in decades and there's
minimal innovation in the Horizon and so
we set out with the mindset that we
could leverage our enduser knowledge as
Physicians to identify treatments that
address real therapeutic challenges
within Dermatology very cool so who's
your demographic that you're looking for
here so we have five products uh the
lead products are for pattern hair loss
also known as androgenetic alopecia and
then for common warts which as their
name suggests are common uh and for each
of those it's right individuals affected
by these conditions who are looking for
better treatment so because I'm not a a
technical or science or a healthcare
person can you explain to me you know
like I'm 10 years old how each of them
Works to Target those conditions yeah so
within the within the bounds of
confidentiality I can I can tell you you
know kind of the the high level there so
for for pattern hair loss the idea right
that's you know baldness that we see
affects 80 million people 50 million men
30 million women most common type of
hair loss and essentially what happens
is that over time the thick scalp hairs
that we all possess you know early in
life start to thin and then eventually
go away we are developing an oral
therapeutic that is non hormonal which
is very important to us that we believe
has great scientific validation that
with Once daily Administration can
assist with hair regrowth and hair
stabilization excellent and talk to me
about the wart one as well yeah so the
wart product is really fascinating the
wart product is essentially a Band-Aid
that has little dissolvable protrusion
that come off it and each of those
protrusions or what we call dissolvable
Micro Ray contains an immune stimulant
and you apply it to the wart in a
process that is virtually painless like
applying a Band-Aid feels a little bit
like pressure and in doing so these
little protrusions dissolve in the skin
kind of like icles melting releasing
these immune stimulants and what we see
happen is that the immune system then
gets revved up in the area so that it
can recognize and fight off the human
papiloma virus which causes warts
leading to wart resolution and and that
therapeutic is currently in a phase 2
study uh so we're very excited anxiously
awaiting results there oh that's so cool
it' be great to have something as easy
as a Band-Aid for that absolutely
applied once every 3 weeks so we think
about you know the remainder of the
therapeutic landscape right there's
freezing with liquid nitrogen you know
fairly painful and you know when we
think about young children who are
disproportionately affected by warps
they simply can't tolerate it or
salicylic acid which is what's in Brands
like Compound W has to be applied every
day for weeks at a time and and and
efficacy is still modest with both these
treatments so we're we're very excited
uh to to hopefully bring something new
excellent now was there something um
personal about starting this company for
you or what was your your founding story
so the founding story is is probably
sillier than anything which is that I
was at uh an American Academy of
Dermatology meeting and I got nominated
to attend this preting for advancing
innovation in dermatology which is an
organization that promotes physician
entrepreneurs and physician innovators
and really tries to take researchers and
have them build real products and so I
attended this conference primarily I
think because it got me out of a day of
work at the time and I was very excited
about that and at the conference I heard
about you know a variety of events and
one of them was an event that they no
longer do unfortunately called hacking
Dermatology uh and I met my co-founder
there uh and the origin of the company
was that basically we're having
breakfast he says to me you know
what if we could administer an immune
stimulant with what is essentially
Band-Aid I that's a great idea croissant
falls out of my mouth and uh yeah now
it's four years later we have five
products uh and we we have that product
in the clinic another product that's
about to start dosing patients really
exciting time for the business very cool
and what were you doing before so I I'm
a board certified dermatologist by
background yeah so uh you know I always
saw myself as someone who would treat
warts on a daily basis but not
necessarily someone who would develop a
treatment for WS so it's very exciting
you know I think a lot of the research
element though came naturally because in
my clinical career I performed quite a
bit of clinical research so serving as a
investigator on you know industry trials
phase two phase three studies uh
published a lot of Articles actually
wrote a textbook which was pretty
exciting uh and so all of that
translated to to
Really the formal landscape well what
was it like to go from the clinical side
to the business side and being an
entrepreneur so I tell people that I
think if I had to pick like what career
probably fit me the best I would be a
like private Equity type person and I
think that the reason I went to medical
school is that I was in high school
during the Great Recession in an area in
Kansas that was particularly hard hit
and my father was a physician and I saw
how you he wasn't worried about losing
his job there was a lot of stability in
our household whereas in the community
around me there was a lot of turmoil and
so I immediately gravitated toward
stability I think my natural skill set
and fit is certainly as a finance person
now talking about Finance tell me about
your funding Journey was it hard to
convince investors to take a chance on
you and how much have you raised so far
so we've raised nearly $40 million and I
think we've been incredibly fortunate in
that identifying many of our critical
investors has occurred very
serendipitously you know not necessarily
through these intentional approaches
that we all employeed to raise Capital
but just during day-to-day interactions
and the original roughly $2 million we
raised all came from Physicians so more
than 25 Physicians they said hey we
recognize that warts are a problem we
recognize that these other dermatologic
conditions need treatment and they
believed in the team and investing in us
and that support then translated into
more of a traditional Venture round I
think people saw that we weren't paying
our KS they were investing in us and
that was really exciting and different
Journey for for most of the investors we
were then fortunate to uh get the
backing of of of Dr Vlad corich who is
the the CEO of biohaven and and John
Childs who's the the managing director
at JW child's Associates what does
fundraising afford your company so the
$40 million has allowed us to take many
of these early stage assets either
Advance them into the clinic two of them
are are now clinical stage a third
should be a clinical stage asset before
the end of the year or do additional
pre-clinical characterization so right
all of these are
heavily regulated products so each of
them must go through the Gambit of
testing to ensure that they're safe
right whether that's you know
non-clinical toxicology or what people
often call you know animal research or
whether that is you know
characterization to say that the
substance that you think you're making
in the lab is in fact what you're making
and so lot of work is gone there current
money is meant to get us through to
hopefully proof of concept generating
readouts for the warp program and the
hair loss program interesting now I know
you're you said you're still pre-revenue
you haven't exactly gone to market yet
can you describe any metrics um that
show the scale of your company as it is
right now yeah so you know the Biotech
Industry in general is all about
competitive advantage that comes with
the regulatory landscape because for
anyone to be an entrant you have to go
through this long process of testing and
so when we think about future value or
when investors try to Value the company
they look at you know Revenue
projections and we've had you know
thirdparty commercial assessments for
example for the pattern hair loss
program where in the us alone we believe
that to be a 1.5 to$ 1.8 billion do a
year Market the reason being again 80
million people right more than 12
million are currently seeking treatment
for their hair loss and there's no
approved oral options in women oral
option in men can cause erectile
dysfunction can cause you know mood
changes and the topical options are
messy they they they don't meet what
people are looking for interesting so
you're based in West Hartford
Connecticut um not typically what one
would consider in Innovation Hub like a
San Francisco or a New York or Boston uh
why did you choose to base the company
there and has it been beneficial for you
so the state of the con Connecticut or
Connecticut Innovations which is the
state's Venture arm has done more for
the company than I could have ever
imagined not only do they hold a roughly
$6 million position in verad dermic but
they provided us with numerous you know
resources whether that be you know a
talent acquisition specialist whether
that be you know PR assistants I mean
they have been tremendous they've helped
us grow our Network and I think that you
will see Connecticut become a biotech
Hub as people want to move out of the
Cities they want to move to places that
are less expensive Connecticut sits
right in the middle between New York and
Boston so we have great talent pools to
pick from and with this growing Life
Science Center and in success stories
like biohaven like our Venus um I think
you're going to see that there there's a
substantial growth of the Biotech
Industry in the state I love that as
someone from Connecticut I'm very glad
to hear it um so Switching gears a bit
what would it take for you to sell your
company and is that your goal so that's
a that's a very complicated question
because you know as you mentioned we're
pre-revenue company and we you know
incur significant development expenses
right clinical trials are extremely
expensive the clinical development
process is extremely expensive and so
there is substantial Capital that has to
be raised now in between you know
approval for a product and you know
currently we're privately held company
company raises you know from private
investors Venture investors you know
crossover investor that type of investor
we seek eventually the company's Capital
needs would be so great we would you
know require a transition of the public
markets so one option would be to go
public continue to finance the company
that way take these products to
commercialization become a revenue
generating company the other option as
you mentioned would be you know sale of
the company sale the asset or
partnership you know each of these can
be done in a combination and the exact
pathway that the company pursues will
you know depend on market conditions
will depend on future investor mix and
will depend on you know continued
success with the development of the
products do you have any goals or dreams
or what you would like to see happen
with the company I would like to see us
develop these Therapeutics get these
products approved and and get them in
the hands of the people who need them
that's amazing now a little bit of a fun
one for you if you could travel back in
time and if you could tell yourself one
piece of advice the day before you
started your company what would you say
oo that is a good question I think that
the answer to that is likely not
everybody gives good advice so I've been
very fortunate we have some tremendous
thought Partners I've got to work with
some of the leading Minds in the
industry people who have been very
generous with their time to you know
help in my growth to Mentor me and to
Mentor the company uh but it is
interesting because as you move through
each phase of the company the thought
leaders or the thought partners that you
need are very very different and I don't
think I appreciated how someone who is
really savvy the seed stage may not
necessarily understand the series be
your crossover stage and then may not
necessarily understand what does it take
to take a company public and having the
right people at the right time to assist
you is just critical how do you find the
right mentors so I I'm a very chatty
individual and I I love to talk to
people and I I firmly believe that most
people if you ask them are very willing
to be to be helpful and I think we can
get people excited about the mission
excited about what we're doing and we've
been very fortunate that that through
working our Network and through cold
Outreach we've been able to get great
people on board awesome is there one
business rule that you operate by no
matter what so I think that one of the
things I read you know you read all
these things and you go is that a good
idea is that a bad idea but one thing I
read that I find to be very true and I I
I try to take into work every day
especially considering I'm not
necessarily a technical expert in every
aspect of our business is that I
approach all our interactions as though
the other person person has a piece of
information that I don't know that I
need to get and you know there are lots
of times where I think it's easier to
tell people tell people tell people and
not ask and everyone in the room is
sitting there they know something you
don't know or they're thinking something
they're all thinking the same thing when
you walk out of the room and so I try to
approach everything with a lot of
questions I think my team would would
say that every interaction with me is is
20 questions but uh I I found that to be
super effective I feel like I've learned
a lot and I feel like I often walk out
of a room with a very different outcome
than I anticipated it's also hard when
you're such a young founder and I feel
like a lot of you know the people in the
under 30 community that I talked to have
like serious impostor syndrome because
they're so young have you ever felt that
and has being young been an advantage
for you or a disadvantage so I think
it's funny because I don't think anyone
has any idea how old I am between the
beard and then sometimes I wear glasses
I think it's very confusing yeah and you
know one of the things that I think has
been different is that I went to medical
school very young so I did a combined B
program at the University of Missouri
Kansas City so out of high school at age
17 I went six years got my ba and MD uh
in that six-year period graduated med
school at 23 then went and did a
residency finished that when I was 27
and so I had a lot of life experience
you know I'm 29 years old but I've had a
lot of life experience and a lot of
working in you know complex team
environments that I think has made it
you know easier to relate to you know
the seasoned far pharmaceutical
executive board members or thought
Partners or employees who have had
really tremendous Journeys working on
you know major approved products very
cool now what's next for you in 2024
where do you see your your company going
any exciting announcements you can share
so 2024 is going to be I'm hopeful our
most exciting year yet right the goal is
always more excitement and 2024 will be
a year where hopefully we will move you
know one product a pattern hair loss
product into a potentially
registrational uh study that we will
advance you know the warp product you
know through the end of its its Phase 2
program hopefully and and in the
remainder of the clinic or remainder of
the products into the clinic you know
clinical development has certainly
timeline variation but but the ultimate
goal is to start testing everything
start getting everything a step closer
to to approval excellent and one last
question for you Reed uh what would you
like your legacy to be that's a that's a
very difficult question and you know I
think at the end of the day most of what
we are doing is about Building Product
and is about building something that has
actual value to the people who use it
and I would hope that you know for
example we have this novel antiviral
that's from mesum that those products
would become synonymous with the
conditions and would really take away
these therapeutic challenges that we're
trying to address well that is a great
answer thank you so much thank you so
much for having me this was
tremendous